did you guys see
the finals viewership what it was the
nba finals viewership check this out
so the nba finals are historically
awful numbers kai if you want to pull
the article up so everybody can see it
game one of the finals was down 45
percent over last year
game two was down 53 percent game three
was down
56 percent game four
uh 42.71 game 551 percent and the last
game
where the championship was won was down
the average viewership numbers of 7.8
million is the lowest number on record
we're talking from 18 million people
watching the finals
to only 7 million people watching the
finals okay
by the way a regular sunday football
game
is 11 million nba is down to 7.4
finals adam finals is what we're talking
about
okay and then daryl mori steps down ted
cruz and mark cuban went at it again i
don't know if you guys saw the exchange
between ted cruz and mark cuban
that that that's a a amazing thing yeah
this was an interesting one that was on
the morning brew this morning
61 percent preakness sticks you know
what we're in a new world everybody
you're going to see all major sports
championships move digital
amazon uh youtube it's done this it's
not working anymore no one wants to
watch stuff with commercials
now the nfl is an anomaly okay the nfl
is its own
beast because the top rated the top 10
rated shows every year are nfl football
what is it with nfl that's so attractive
you know i think more than nba it's an
event women like it and you got gambling
gambling sucks people in fantasy leagues
and people have money riding on these
games it means eyeballs
yeah how much of it you think this has
to do with bringing too much politics
into
twenty percent twenty percent you don't
even think that it's a big of a deal
um i think it's a deal i think i think
they have the perfect storm it's it's
that
it's basketball in october and people
not used to that
and the whole just everything pandemic
add it all up and it was a disaster okay
so everything was down
stanley cup's down 60 preakness down 56
nba finals down 49 down down down down
down down down but look what's
up this is weird to me pga tour
non-major cbd
that makes sense because there was
nothing else on wnba finals wnba finals
was up 15
pga championship final round up three
percent
why was the wa wnba finals i have no
idea
why i think you watch it you're like
your community it's uh
all four of my friends it's up 15 way to
go percent
i mean you know so it's bigger than that
have you ever watched the wnba finals
highlights oh okay so you've seen some
of the highlights
yeah but never the finals never watched
the floor have you ever watched a full
game
never i support my friend diana taurasi
i have well she's a beast she's the best
she's a beast i have to disable you know
diana i know her bell yeah she's
she's a she's not doesn't manhattan beat
she's great she's legendary on how she
[Music]
is